I'm the best of what I do and what I do
isn't very nice
[Applause]
[Music]
so having suffered my way through x-men
Dark Phoenix I'm sorry just our Phoenix
they were too ashamed to put the name
x-men on the title I've now seen all of
Fox's x-men movies which means I'm okay
to rank them and no do not get on my
butt saying oh well shouldn't you wait
for new mutants that thing was supposed
to come out like over a year ago at this
point I will be shocked if it ever sees
release and I'm not waiting for it
hoping that it will come out before I do
this list
you've gotta clear this off the board
and be done with it quick note if people
are uncomfortable either revisiting
these movies or even talking about these
movies because of some things we've
learned about some of the directors
involved specifically Bryan Singer and
Brett Ratner I am NOT gonna fault you
for that but I'm not factoring that in
to this ranking I'm simply taking the
movies as they exist and not factoring
that into this thing that means I have
12 of these things to rank let's get to
it starting at the bottom x-men
apocalypse this thing I have described
as aggressively mediocre and that might
seem a little bit odd to put it at the
bottom spot cuz like mediocre just means
like not very good doesn't mean awful
that's the thing though it's not that
the bad elements of Apocalypse are the
worst thing to ever occur in the x-men
film series it's that there's absolutely
nothing that's good about it the lows
aren't the lowest but there's literally
no highs in this movie the few things
that are any good at all ie Magneto
snapping and the Quicksilver scene are
both derivative retreads of stuff the
series had already done better so
there's nothing that this thing has to
offer
lousy villain phone didn't performances
from about
half the cast and the effects look bad
the storage is just dull and boring and
no just no moving up to number 11 Dark
Phoenix Dark Phoenix is not really a
better movie than Apocalypse was the
difference is and I mentioned this in my
review it was bad in ways that I found
more interesting so as opposed to simply
being aggressively mediocre it was at
least kind of creatively bad like wow
you you found some really interesting
ways to screw this up and yes that is a
massively backhanded compliment if it
counts as any kind of compliment at all
but it does mean end of the day I would
watch Dark Phoenix again before I would
watch pocalypse again and so for
whatever that's worth it gets the number
11 spot next up number 10 x-men origins
Wolverine people loved to crap all over
this one and it is a bit of a mess it's
got characters who have no business
being in it it's got a funky structure
to it it is cartoonish in its effects
often as it works its way through but
you know what it has it's got two things
Jackman is still doing his job he's not
phoning it in he's trying and Liev
Schreiber as Sabretooth is so good like
to the point that I am legitimately
ticked off he never came back
I get that they wanted to distance
themselves as far as possible from my
x-men origins Wolverine cuz it's not
very good but he was so good in that
part he's him and Jackman are really the
only good things going on in it the rest
is just yeah just kind of nonsense and
dull and silly and do who shows
Deadpool's mouth shop hey yeah we'll
move on next up number 9 this one hurt
x-men the original from 2000
this is one of those movies that it was
pretty good at the time but it does not
hold up and a lot of the decisions made
that word decisions of the time reflect
badly things like the yellow spandex
line really highlight that this movie is
running away as hard as it can from
appearing to be a comic-book movie it is
embarrassed by its source material and
that comes across pretty readily across
the film that said it's got some stuff
going for it primarily in the casting
area Patrick Stewart as Professor Xavier
brilliant Ian McKellen as magneto
inspired Hugh Jackman as Wolverine
terrific find and pretty much all the
other actors are doing a good job to the
the way that mystique was visualized
iconic very cool it's an important first
step in a lot of ways as far as book not
only this franchise but superhero movies
in general go but looking back on it now
it's dull it's pedestrian it's as I said
kind of embarrassed by what it is and
pretty much all the things that are good
about it and there are some things that
are good about it are even better later
on so this ends up down here number 8
x-men The Last Stand now I know some
people that are meeting question is why
in the heck is this ranked higher than
the original x-men film well first of
all I'm a slight apologist for this
movie I will just flat-out own that and
you know it just the the movie had a bum
rap going in the situation was not good
that the the conditions under which it
was made were not ideal but even setting
that aside it's got one thing that for
me puts it over the original x-men scope
scale it brings in that operatic feel
that x-men stories tend to have in the
comics and I like that being there and
then the other stuff that's good in it
is pretty much all the stuff that was
good in the first x-men you know there's
some wonky effects stuff going on but
Ian McKellen so good Patrick Stewart
still good Hugh Jackman still good we
get a couple of new characters who are
also quite good kelsey Grammer's great
as beasts and heck you know what I'll
say it I like Vinnie Jones as the
juggernaut it's still not great but I
get a little bit more enjoyment out of
it once I'm past the fact that Cyclops
it was completely casually discarded as
if he was a snotty handkerchief as
opposed to a founding member of the team
at a core character in the franchise
overall like once I muscle past that I
do find enjoyment out of it number seven
Deadpool - I really didn't care for
Deadpool - I'll just say it now part of
that is expectation I really wanted this
film to go bigger and bolder
conceptually I wanted it to do something
less traditional now that the superhero
narrative and origin improve of concept
of the first film was done and dusted I
wanted this to go nuts and it really
only does that with the x-force sequence
that is what I wanted kind of the whole
movie to be but it doesn't have the guts
to do Everett Red's too many jokes from
the previous one and I really hate the
fact that they frigid Vanessa that
having been said it's still pretty well
put together it's pretty confident
Domino is awesome and cables pretty well
realized all things considered so it's
not bad I have a personal distaste for
it and as far as sequels go I consider
it to be a letdown but it gets above the
ones that I mentioned before but no
higher than this number six and we start
getting into the film's that I think are
just they're good
and I don't really have too much to slag
off about them although I do know some
people who are gonna want my head on a
pike for where I'm about to put this one
number six x-men first class I know some
people who genuinely consider this to be
the best x-men movie made and as far as
I'm concerned those people are nuts
nothing is bad it's quite good I enjoy
it and I think the cast is solid all the
way through I think the vibe that they
got with the 60s is kind of a cool thing
I really like how the way that James
McAvoy and Michael Fassbender were able
to recapture and be true to that dynamic
a Patrick Stewart and he and McKellen
that is no small feat to be able to pull
off the Wolverine cameo was genius and
it's pretty well put together but there
are some characters who seem superfluous
and don't need to be there you know
Darwin being used as fodder felt very
off-putting when I saw that and then
Emma Frost
really she seems checked out there are
little things like that that just don't
quite do it for me I'm also while I
appreciate they pulled the 60s vibe
quite well I'm not a particular sucker
for that broadly speaking and I suspect
my friends who rank this higher than I
do are that might be part of what's
going on for them it's good don't get me
wrong but this is where it lands for me
moving up from here number five x-men
Days of Future past
I liked this a lot as an end point as a
closing of the book on that era of x-men
and actually at this point I'm gonna
consider that the end of the franchise
because what came after was Apocalypse
and then Dark Phoenix so I will just
pretend forevermore that x-men d'leh
that it's the last 1000 no that x-men
Days of Future past was the end of it I
liked the pulling together of the two
different timelines I feel like it tied
a nice bow around the original timeline
the original characters gave them a nice
happy ending and it worked quite
for that I liked the interconnectedness
of the story I liked the way it played
back and forth does it have a few
logistical plot holes yeah most
time-travel stories do but I really did
enjoy this then I'd like to the way that
it captured both the sense of
progression forward of the story but
also capturing a sense of nostalgia and
it balanced all that stuff really well I
thought number 4 Deadpool so yeah it was
good it was a breath of fresh air and it
was nice you know just to hear Wade
Wilson actually get to talk do his thing
be a jerk and it's a good time and the
actions a lot of fun and some of the
stuff that goes on with Colossus and III
love negasonic teenage warhead that's
like the best but also like he's hunting
found this guy named Francis and making
fun of the fact that he's named Francis
it's little things like that it's it's
letting Wade take you on a trip a little
crazy trip of an adventure and it's just
fun number three most people wouldn't
put this one this high The Wolverine if
it worked for the third act this would
have a shot at my favorite x-men movie
period I love the first two-thirds of
this thing I love setting up Wolverine
as a ronin I love how they need tapped
his a healing factor so things felt much
more visceral and much more dangerous
I loved the fight choreography I loved
the cinematography I loved the setting
the vibe the tone the performances
Jackman he never phoned in this
performance at any part and he's
definitely doing his best with it here
if it wasn't for the climax basically
the film kind of falls apart from the
point at which he gets taken down by all
the arrows on chains
after that the movie goes downhill
because the climaxes with the villain
that is supposed to be a surprise but I
called way early into the film and the
final fight is just kind of dumb but the
first two-thirds is so strong that it
makes it this high regardless I really
love the first two-thirds of this movie
wish you could have stuck the landing oh
well that's okay because you know why we
still got number two Logan oh you know I
have hit a point in my life where my
tolerance level for nihilistic
everything sucks
storytelling my tolerance has gone down
I don't have the taste for it and the
stomach for it that I used to have but
you know what when it's good it's good
and this is good this just again the
x-men franchise in the films is that
it's best when it knows what to emulate
that's a big part of what I like about
the Wolverine because it's emulating
that sort of samurai sense and and
groanin stories and this is emulating
the aging cowboy the West
the gunslinger who's past his prime it's
evoking all of that and doing it
perfectly the sense of him slowing down
not having anything left not really
having anything to live for but he's
just too stubborn doesn't just slow down
and stop even though maybe he would
rather do that and God the stuff going
on with Charles is heartbreaking Laura's
great what a great presence that actress
is it's harsh it's hard yet it's
satisfying in a very strange and dark
way it just feels like okay you get to
stop now Logan thanks and as much as it
has been on for a long time it remains
my number one for this franchise
x2 x-men United this is where it all
came together for me the characters and
the actors who are cast in these roles
who were all well cast in the first
x-men film getting to do just a little
bit more mystique having an iconic lines
like when being asked why doesn't she
pretend to look human all the time she
says because we shouldn't have to the
cockiness of Magneto and just knowing
that he's teaming up with the x-men for
now but he's gotta stab them in the back
the instant he gets the chance
Nightcrawler so cool I love Kurt vogner
as a character he's fantastic
and the tension around what's going on
with Charles that he gets kidnapped on
what is going to be done with him the
angst that Hugh Jackman gets to portray
playing Wolverine as he's getting taste
of his past but still doesn't quite know
what it is that's going on we get his
first we could see him go berserk for
basically the first time that just kicks
a lot of butt
this feels like the perfect balance of
escalation while not losing control of
the characters and the emotion because
as much as I did point out that x-men
the last and felt nice and big and
operatic which I appreciated it kind of
lost control of some of the elements
when it went that big this feels just
right it takes the elements it's got
it's got everything from the nailing
down of mutation as a parallel to being
queer that was a wonderful move laid out
completely explicitly here I love that
the temptation of pyro is done extremely
well all this all these elements all
these bits these pieces they fit
together in a way that for me no other
film and the franchise quite fit the
pieces together in just right like this
one did so for me it's number one I have
a feeling a lot of people are gonna have
very different rankings from me but what
are you
thoughts on this how do you rank the
x-men films now that this franchise is
done and will eventually find out what
it is Disney plans to do with them
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it a whole bunch of stuff to
do cuz you can support me on patreon
help me keep the lights on and you know
eat plus there's you know like in the
SUBSCRIBE and the bell and all sorts of
stuff click on things they do stuff when
you do that or you know don't you don't
have to because at the end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council's adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]